hello i'm matthias the founder of
data in this video i explain everything to you in a
simple way and in the valley in
level the even level is
one of the most important
properties of variables in statistics it is
so important that the permissible
arithmetic operations are determined and thus the
possible statistical tests the
higher the even level, the more
comparison statements and right operation
are possible, so here about the even
level, the more statistical tests
are possible the level of a variable
can either be nominally original or
scalar or metric in
short phenomenal variables
can be the characteristics
so we can distinguish
between a b c and d
with original variables the expression can be
sorted so we
can say is smaller than bbs smaller
c&c is an sc and with metric sky
level the distances between the expressions can then also be
calculated and now go  we  on
each of the individual ska levels let's
start with the nominal ska level
of the nominal even level is the
lowest level in the statistics and
it therefore has the lowest
information content possible characteristics of
the variables can be differentiated
, but a meaningful order is
not possible
what characterizes a nominal
scale first of all only relationships
equal and unequal are possible no
logical ranking of the categories is
possible the order of the answers
is completely interchangeable nominal
characteristics with only two
values ​​are also referred to as the nation
as an example of nominal
variables we can use gender  hertaking with
the characteristics male female the marital status
single married
divorced or widowed or which
newspaper you prefer to read
bild -zeitung schutz- or handelsblatt
with all these variables you can
differentiate the characteristics
but it is n  It doesn't make sense to create a
ranking if we
have a questionnaire, for example, it
doesn't matter whether the bild newspaper comes up first and then
the faz,
it's exactly the other way around that brings us to
the original ska st
the original scale is the next
higher risk booked it contains nominal
information
only with the difference that a
ranking is formed therefore
the term sans gala is
often used
the distances between the characteristics
cannot be interpreted in these cases, however
,
a statement about the absolute
headstand between two values ​​is therefore
not possible
the properties of an original
scale are therefore statements that are equal and
unequal the larger and smaller they
can be made there is a
logical ranking of the categories the
distances between the numbers are
not equal and therefore not
interpretable
as an example we can never know how often
and tv shows i.e. the frequency of
tv  ens or a question the
federal government is doing a good job
in the first case frequency the television
can have questions several times a
week a day seldom or never it is very clear
that these
characteristics can be differentiated and it is also very clear
that we can rank these characteristics
in a
survey, for example, it would
make no sense if there were first several times a
week and then every
day and then seldom in a
questionnaire we will have questions in exactly this order
just as with the
question the federal government is
doing a good job we also more precisely agree to
undecided  or reject these
questions we shouldn't get confused now
the last gallego the
metric sga level is the highest
level at metric sky level
the more than characteristics can be compared and
sorted and
the distances between the house characteristics
can also be calculated, i.e. the property
and that goes r  really even level is
once that is the highest level it
is possible that you
can also say the following floors are equal below the same are of
course possible and from a larger
smaller ones are also possible and the
differences at the moment can be meaningfully
formed
as an example you can  here income is
accepting weight age and
power consumption as a guide how you can't
even tell the metric level from the
originals it
's that if you now create a
survey and ask about income
it's quite clear to the respondents that
they're easy  enter a value just
like when you ask for the weight it is
exactly clear for the person
i write the numbers exactly as well
as with the age or the
power consumption on the other hand with the original
sky nico you always have to describe in words
what exactly you mean by that,
for example if  I
ask how often I watch television, where I
always define myself precisely  n what is 1 what is
2 what is three to four that metro is
even level can still be divided into the two
areas of white gala and relationship
karla
i have prepared two examples
for this let's first look at the
example for the hated ones it will be
the  times measured by marathon
runners the statement can be
made that the fastest runner is
twice as fast as the last
runner this is possible because there is an absolute
high point at the beginning of the
marathon in which all runners start from zero
so it is very important when
there is a ratio of bile  an absolute
zero point example for the inter white
grana is forgotten at the start of the
marathon the stop courses
start and it will go out to the
fastest runners where the differences
can be measured the runners cannot be compared
in this case it can be said
how big the interval between  the
runners are eg dorfes 22 minutes
faster than  runner b
, however, it cannot be said that
runner a ran 20 percent faster
svb this is not possible because there is
no absolute zero point at the prize
gala so and with that we now have
a big exercise if you want
you can take a short break and  for
yourself the table continuously
otherwise we will punish the
individual cases together we will start with
the first one the place of residence in Germany
the place of residence in Germany is of course
escalated nominally you can write the place of residence
in Germany but it is
not possible to rank
the second point  the product rating
on a scale from 1 to 5
this is original escalated you can
distinguish the expression and it is
possible to form a ranking
the religious belief is
nominally escalated again it is possible to distinguish the
religious
belief but you cannot form a ranking the
co2 emissions per year is  metric a
ratio cover the  iq of pupils is
also metric and an interview the
exam mark from 1 to 5 original one
can distinguish the grade and one can
also rank the
telephone number of interviewees is nominal
one can distinguish the telephone numbers
but it is not possible
to rank during the
care level of a patient is
original and the living space in square meters of
course metric job
satisfaction and a scale from
one to four up to goal so i
hope the video has helped my understanding
of scale levels if
not or if you just have questions
i'll leave them  Just send me comments
and I would be happy to
answer them for you.
just know google on the parents
you will find great tutorials and evaluate
your data directly online in
no time at all
if you want to be informed
as soon as a new video of mine
comes out just subscribe to it  then
says and click on the klin  ge so
bye and see you next time